FIFTEENTH APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
AT NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHAT WE'LL DO IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TAKE TESTIMONY ON
BILLS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE NOT ON THE SUSPENSE AND
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON A BILL
ON SUSPENSE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL TAKE
YOUR SUPPORTER POST POSITION AT
THE END OF THE HEARING SO START
WITH THAT MISTER O'DONNELL.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WHEN WE
GET A QUORUM IT WILL ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ARE YOU READY MANAGER.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE NINE ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE WHICH INCENTIVIZE IS THE
REPLACEMENT OF NATURAL GAS WITH
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
BY EXTENDING THE LC FS CREDIT
AVAILABLE FOR SUCH REPLACEMENT
OIL PRODUCERS.
THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT IN ORDER
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS MUST BE
GENERATED BY A SOURCE THAT WILL
DIRECTLY REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL NOT ONLYREDUCE THE
GHG FOOTPRINT OF ALL OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS BUT IT ALSO ASSISTS
IN CREATING A STRONGER IN STATE
MARKET FOR METHANE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE.
DISSIPATE INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
AND POSSIBLY HERE TO TESTIFY AS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPES START
TRADE COUNCIL BUT I DO NOT SEE
THAT WITH THAT.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
SPEAKER SINCE PART.
I SHALL WE IS THE RESORT
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS MIKE MONEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL AS SORRY FOR
BEING TARDY.
STRONG SUPPORT TO MR DOWNS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME
ASSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DO NOT THE FILE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS -- OBVIOUSLY
WE CAN'T YET.
BRING EMOTION BUT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
LAST RIVAL WHEN IT COMES TIME
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL THANK
YOU.
MISTER KALRA.
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE TO BILLS UP
TODAY.
START WITH AB FIFTY NINE ENJOYS
A DEEP HOUSE RECOMMENDATION.
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB
FIFTY NINE BILLS UPON OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND VOTER
TURNOUT.
AMONG SOME VOTERS THE BILL WOULD
PRIORITIZE PLACEMENT THE VOTE
CENTER OR SATELLITE OFFICE ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ACROSS THE
STATE.
REGARDING THE FISCAL ESTIMATES
YES YOU SACRAMENTO HOSTED ABOUT
CENTER FOR BOTH THE PRIMARY AND
GENERAL ELECTION FOR FOUR DAYS
EACH HAS BEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
DOLLARS TOTAL.
ADDITIONALLY SPOKE WITH TO
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THAT ALSO
GOES TO BOTH CENTER SKYLINE AND
NAPA VALLEY AND THEY SAW VERY
MINIMAL CLASS SPEC THE ASPEN
ABOUT.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE FILES.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA I KNOW
THAT -- YOU'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ON AMENDMENTS IS THAT.
YES I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH ON
MONDAY WHEN HE TO WORK WITH
SURFACED IT'S OFFICE WONDERFUL --
I SEE NO QUESTIONS.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE CHáVEZ
REMEMBER ALL RIGHT.
AT THE NEXT WILL BE AB SIX FORTY
SEVEN IT WILL ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS COSMETICS
DISINFECTANTS WHO ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
POST ITS.
SAFETY DATA SHEETS ONLINE AND
TRANSLATE INTO UPON OF LANGUAGES
SPOKEN BY SALON PROFESSIONALS.
AS THE ANALYSIS KNOWS COST A
DOLLAR MINOR STUFF WE ASK.
FOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR KAREN LAYING
ON THE OTHER THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE.
NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE VAST RATHER WHEN WE
GET WARM WE WILL TAKE THOSE UP
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA THANK YOU.
MESS GOMEZ ADDRESS.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IT WILL
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN A SIMPLE
BILL WITH WHICH PROPOSES. TO
DISSOLVE THE EXISTING ON THE
TRANS JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY AND
REFORM ACT INTO OMNITRANS
SPECIAL TRANSIT DISTRICT.
I'M ADDRESSES THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCY THAT WAS FORMED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CURRENTLY
OFFERS PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER TO DO NO
VALLEY.
SERVING CITIES INCLUDING COLD IN
FONTANA GRANT TERRACE REALTORS
HAMMER TO DO YOU KNOW.
ALL OF WHICH ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
HELP PROVIDING NEW INNOVATIVE
AND VITAL TRANSPORTATION SERVICE
TO THE INLAND EMPIRE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHILE.
UP TO PARK IN QUESTION YEAH IS
THERE A REASON THIS DIDN'T GO
THROUGH THE LAUGHTER PROCESS.
I'M SORRY IS THE REASON THIS
DIDN'T GO THROUGH THE LEFT CO
PROCESS IT'S GOING TO THE LACK
OF PROFIT PROCESS -- SO -- BUT
WE STILL NEED TO BE NOW WHAT WE
ARE STILL IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH A
LAUGH CO THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
ADDED ON THEY HAVE BEEN.
IN THE PROCESS THE ENTIRE TIME
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
THANK YOU AND SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM ARE AWFULLY CLOSE --
LET'S NOW.
DOCTOR QUIRK DO YOU HAVE AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ACTUALLY ONE
OF YOUR BILLS.
IT WILL ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
JUST A REMINDER THAT IF ANYONE'S
WATCHING WE DO NEED AUTHORS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE LOCALS SHE'S ME LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES TO PAY. FOR THE
INDIRECT COSTS THAT THEIR
PORTFOLIOS IMPOSE ON THE
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM.
WHICH WHICH AND THE PRICE SIGNAL
THAT WILL ENCOURAGE WELL
BALANCED PORTFOLIO TO SERVE
CUSTOMER NEEDS.
THIS MEASURE WILL HAVE NEVER
NEGLIGIBLE COST TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A EXPERT
WITNESS BUT I SURE YOU CAN
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
GREAT I'M GONNA HOLD YOU RIGHT
THERE WHILE WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM [inaudible]
MA'AM SECRETARY [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
DEEP.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
GABRIEL.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MISSION [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
NORTH.
QUIRK CARE RIVAS.
THANK YOU AND THIS ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW A SECOND BY A MR
OBERNOLTE -- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CARE ALSO BE HALF
THE CITY OF SOLANO BEACH IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK YOU WILL.
ALL RIGHT IF WE COULD -- TAKE UP
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE I MISTER
O'DONNELL I'VE A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW.
A SECOND BY MISTER A MAN -- THAT
GETS OUT ON IT A ROLL CALL -- AB
FIFTY NINE BY MISTER KALRA.
WITH A MOTION BY MISS EGGMAN AS
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
THAT GETS OUT WITH MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
WAIT ON AND BE ROLL CALL WITH MR
OBERNOLTE VOTING HI.
AB.
SIX FORTY SEVEN BY MISTER KALRA
AND THAT'S ON CALL.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY A
MYSTERIOUS
-- THAT WAS A MOTION
BY A MISTER DOCTOR QUIRK AND
SECOND BY MISS EIGHT MEN.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR BIGELOW MISTER FONG NOT
VOTING.
WE ARE CAUGHT UP EXCEPT WE HAVE
ONE BUILT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO MORE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO PRESENT
BILLS TODAY THAT MEANS.
AND THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES AND
THIS IS LITERALLY WHAT YOUR LAST
OPPORTUNITY SO -- I HOPE PEOPLE
ARE COMING DOWN WE NEED.
MR CHIU THAT'S KANSEN SHOW
MISTER COLLEY MISTER GALLAGHER
MISS -- WHEN?
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
WE NEED ONE THOSE AUTHORS IN THE
NEXT.
I WILL SIT HERE FOR FIVE MINUTES
BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
A MOTION BY MS SEGMENT.
EGGMAN.
A SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
WILL YOU PLEASE -- MA'AM
SECRETARY READ THE CONSENT
COUNTER.
AB TWO A ONE SIX SEVENTY SIX
SEVEN SIXTY TWO EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE A 729-408-9110 541-089-1160
1-240-812-5712. 691-406-1450
615-601-6403 1-640-418-2318
TWENTY FOUR AND EIGHTEEN THIRTY
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON
THE CONSENT -- AND THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL AT THIS TIME IF --
MANSER TREE WILL PLEASE.
LIST THE BILLS THAT ARE MADE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AB 510-243-9120 313-614-01160
1-195-265-2664 OR 542-342-7480
FIVE OH EIGHT FIVE TWELVE BY
FIFTEEN BY THIRTY SIX BY.
686-276-4016 568-371-5740
575-376-3760 777-787-84790
1-812-813-8268 495-489-9149
369-381-0001 WITHOUT THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX AND
671-080-1120. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN ELEVEN FORTY OF THEM.
561-152-1160 911-751-22212
421-240-91250 912-681-27513.
TWELVE THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN FORTY THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE THIRTEEN FORTY TWO THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR THIRTY SIXTY
SIX THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE FOURTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX FIFTEEN OH
NINE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTEEN NINETY
SIXTEEN OH SIX SIXTEEN ELEVEN
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN FORTY TO
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY --
WITH MOVING THOSE TO THE SYSTEM
SUSPENSE FILE WITH THAT MAKES
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLS
THAT WE WILL DISPENSE OF
TOMORROW -- IF THERE IS ANYBODY
IN THE AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ONE OF THE BILLS
JUST READ FOR THE SUSPENSE VALUE
MAY MOVE TO THE MICROPHONE NOW
AND DO THAT.
SEEN NONE OF WE GOT. ONE TOO WE
ASK YOU KEEP THE SHORE JUST LET
US KNOW WHO WE ARE AND WHAT YOU
FEEL.
MARK TONY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
WE OPPOSE AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX THAT WOULD BE
GONZALEZ.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION -- VINCENT LAY
COUNSEL WITH THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE.
WE ALSO OPPOSE AT AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CURTIS
LÏNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION -- WE OPPOSE
A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR WE OPPOSE AB
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU.
AT WE STILL DO NEED AS A
DEMOCRAT FROM THE COMMITTEE TO
SHOW UP TO GET SOMETHING OFF
CALL AND WITH THAT MR COOLEY AND
MISTER DOCTOR QUIRK IS GOING TO
PRESENT FOR MR COOLEY.
AB THIRTEEN NO ONE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MS CARILLO A
SECOND BY MISTER EGGMAN.
WELL I'M GONNA USE MY OWN SOME
REPAIR.
THIS WANTS TO LARA.
AREA.
THE BILL REQUIRES BEGINNING JULY --
ONE TWENTY TWENTY COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES TO COMPENSATE
LICENSED PRIVATE ADOPTION.
AGENCIES FOR THE UNREIMBURSED
COSTS -- SUPPORTING FAMILIES
THROUGH THE ADOPTION PROCESS.
AND I HOPE I HAVE AN EXPERT HERE.
THANK YOU SIR CABBIES UNDERLING
AB MACDONALD FOR THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THE SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION.
BASICALLY WHAT THE BILL IS DOING
IS TAKING THIS VERY LONG
STANDING -- IT'S A YEAR YOUNGER
THAN I AM I MEAN IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME I WON'T
SAY HOW LONG EXACTLY UP PRIVATE
AGENCY ADOPTION REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAM THAT HELPS SUPPORTED
OPTIONS.
AND PULLING IT OUT OF THE STATE
AND PUTTING IT TO THE COUNTIES
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT IT WAS ALWAYS
THE INTENT TO DO THIS WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH EXACTLY HOW TO
DO THAT LOGISTICALLY.
THE BILL -- WILL I AVOID HAVING
A CONTRACT WITH EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY BY UTILIZING OUR
PLACEMENT AGREEMENT AND IT
SHOULD BE COST NEUTRAL IN THE
SENSE THAT WE'RE JUST TAKING THE
FUNDS ARE ALREADY REALIGNED.
BUT THAT THE COUNTIES OF ME
GETTING TO THE STATE AND INSTEAD
GIVE THOSE TO THE COUNTY SWEEP --
DRIVER THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST
A SPORT KAREN LAYING ON THE OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THANK YOU -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WELL NOW THAT I UNDERSTAND I
REALLY REALLY AREN'T YOUR I'VE
OUT.
THAT THANK YOU THAT BILL -- IS
ON CALL AND AGAIN -- SOME OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT
HERE.
MR BONTA MISTER CALDERON MR
GABRIEL ARE MISTER GARCIA.
AT THIS POINT -- WERE YOU GONNA
DO NOT PRESENT.
THAT I'M PARTICULARLY FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT.
ABSOLUTELY ALRIGHT.
SO MISTER SANTIAGO'S A. B..
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WOULD EXEMPT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECTS.
PAID FOR IN WHOLE OR PART BY
PROPOSITION TRIPLE H. AND STATE
FUNDED EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE ALL KNOW
THE DIFFICULTY OF CITING THESE
ARE THE ABUSES SEEK WHETHER IT'S
OFTEN GIVEN -- TO PREVENT THE
CITING SO I THINK IT'S AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THEY'LL AND
WHEN I FULLY SUPPORT.
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO.
THE SECOND BY A DOCTOR EGGMAN --
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
THANK YOU AND I DON'T QUIRK THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AND THEN
I ALSO VIçT FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THE MISTER GALLAGHER'S
BILL AB.
FOUR THIRTY IS A STASH IT'S IT'S
NOT REALLY THAT IS MY WHAT
MISTER BIGELOW IN ITS SECOND BY
DOCTOR EGGMAN YEAH IS
ESTABLISHES A MINI MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS. FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN OR NEAR THE
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN SO RAVAGED
BY THE FIRES -- I JUST CAN'T
IMAGINE OF WHAT THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE GONE THROUGH.
AND THAT THIS WOULD MAKE IT NOT
SUBJECT TO REVIEW UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADD SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR CAROLING ON
BEHALF OF THE BUTTE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE DEVASTATION
IS INDESCRIBABLE AND WE WOULD
URGE APPROVAL OF THIS MATTER
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
JOHN KENNEDY WITH WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR PLACED
HER BIGELOW RICHARD HERMAN
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VIRE
MILITANT FENCE.
CENTER IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS SET FORTH IN MY
TESTIMONY THAT I SUBMITTED ON
MAY FOURTEENTH -- IT'S NOT
NECESSARY WE CAN'T AFFORD IT
PLEASE DO NOT APPROVE THIS
PROJECT WITHOUT.
PROVIDING FUNDING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE DUCT WORK.
AS WE ARE VOTE -- AND THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
DISPENSE OF AB SIX FORTY SEVEN
BY MISTER KALRA THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND
AB THIRTEEN NO ONE MISTER
KLEENEX OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT.
VOTING -- MR ONE IS HERE.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
MR ONCE PRESSING ON AB EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE DETROIT TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR EGGMAN A SECOND BY A MISS
CARILLO.
THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE -- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT A SEVEN THREE
THIS BILL IS THE RESULT OF
EXTENSIVE WORK BY THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TO BRING BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND
UNDERSTAND TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THIS YOU SEE PA.
THIS BILL TAKES ON TWO ISSUES
THE DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION INFORMATION AND THE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED WE
WORK WITH THE PROPONENT OF THE
PRIVACY ADDITION -- INITIATIVE.
ALISTAIR THAGARD AND POLICY
COMMITTEE AND TOOK HIS GROUP
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION WITH ME
TODAY SIR BOTH FROM THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON THE HAVE A CANTIERE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
LEADERS IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE.
IT HAS A MOTION SECOND -- THAT
GETS OUT AND IN A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PROPERTY.
TO MR WHEN IS GONNA PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE FILE AB.
TWELVE FORTY TWO YES -- TWELVE
FORTY TWO PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE AND GEO THE
LACK OF CYBERSECURITY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CERTAIN AND
ACTUALLY MISTER WHEN I AM SO
SORRY TO DO THIS FOR YOU BUT IN
AND REMAINING CONSISTENT WE RT
ACTUALLY MOVE THAT'S A SUSPENSE
FILES YOU CAN'T PRESENT ON IT.
I'M SORRY OKAY BUT THAT THAT IS
OUR RULES SO WE TAKE THAT ACTION
BECAUSE WE ARE WAITING ON
AUTHORS AND I'M TERRIBLY SORRY.
THANK YOU THE D'ARTAGNAN IS
GOING TO PRESENT FOR MISS QUIRK
SILVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING -- I
AM HERE TO RESIGN AB SIX TWENTY
SIX WHICH AMENDS THE PROVISIONS
RELATING TO REMOTE INTEREST IN
SECTION TEN NINETY ONE OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE IN ORDER TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO QUALIFIED
CONSULTANTS.
REPUBLIC WERE PROJECT EVEN
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO.
A SECOND BY.
MR CHOW.
BECAUSE IN SUPPORT JOHN MOFFITT
ON BEHALF OF THE CDC CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MARC CHRISTIAN WITH
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE [inaudible]
DUCT WORK.
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
BILL.
WITH THIS BE PEOPLE WHO COULD BE
CONTRACTED.
OUT [inaudible]
THESE CONSULTANTS -- WITH A
ALREADY BE CONTRACTED FOR THIS
PROJECT AND THEN WE MADE
CONSULTANT ON THE PROJECT OR
THEY SIMPLY ARE ELIGIBLE HOW
EXACTLY DOES THIS.
WORK.
THE BILL DEALS WITH -- DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS SO IN IN OUR CASE
ENGINEERS WHO DO AN EARLY.
EARLY STAGE WORK ON A PROJECT
AND SELL MAYBE IT'S AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE CITY SAYS WE
NEED A BRIDGE HERE.
SHOULD BE TWO LINES ARE FOUR
LANE SHOULD HAVE SIDEWALKS AND
SO THEY WOULD GO OUT.
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT WITH THE
CITY AND THEN ONCE THAT PHASE
ENDS.
THIS COULD BE FUTURE PHASES OF
THAT SAME PROJECT A NEW R. F. P.
GOES OUT A NEW COMPETITIVE.
YES PROCESS SO THERE NEVER PAID
BY THE CONTRACTOR.
CORRECT OKAY THEN I UNDERSTAND
ALLEN'S CERTAINLY WILL SUPPORT
IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SCENE NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AS FOR YOUR BILL
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR BONTA MISTER FONG AND
MISTER OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
WE'RE DOWN TO MISTER KANSEN SURE.
THANK YOU CHAU MISSION TO MY MY
BROTHER AS YOU KNOW.
AB SEVEN NINETY TO ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION -- THE BILL
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE
MINUTES SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
YES IT REQUIRES THE I'M SORRY
THAT SEVEN TWENTY NINE NINE
SEVEN SOMETHING HOUSE YES IT
REQUIRES THE CAPITAL -- STE
EXCUSE ME REQUIRES A CARPET
STEWARDSHIP PLAN. TO INCLUDE A
CONTINGENCY PLAN THAT
DEMONSTRATES HOW THE ACTIVITIES
IN THE PLAN.
CONTINUE TO BE CARRIED OUT IN
ABSENCE OF AN APPROVED PLAN
EITHER BY THE ORGANIZATION OR BY
CAL RECYCLED THROUGH AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY SUCH AS AN
ESCROW COMPANY.
WONDERFUL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MORE AND CHAIR WITH GREAT
CAMPBELL INTERFACE INTERFACE IS
A A LARGE CARPET -- MANUFACTURED
RECYCLER AND WE'RE MEMBERS OF
CARE AND WE THINK THAT THESE.
CAL RECYCLE AMENDMENTS -- MAKE
THE BILL MORE RESPONSIVE TO
ACTUALLY GETTING CAL RECYCLING
OF CORPORATE IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUST ALL SPEAKERS AND
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING -- MICROBES IN HERE
ON BEHALF OF MOHAWK INDUSTRIES A
CARPET MANUFACTURER --
PARTICIPATES IN THE IN THE CARE
PROGRAM -- JUST REALLY QUICK
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL NOW
SAYS POINTS OUT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL IS -- TO IS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO DO WITH CARP
RECYCLING FUNDS SHOULD THE
EXISTING IT SHOULD CARE THE
EXISTING STORAGE ORGANIZATION
DISSOLVER OR CALL WAY -- THE
BILL GOES WAY BEYOND THAT AND IT
HAS TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR DAY
PENALTIES FOR FOR FOR VIOLATIONS
THAT ARE.
NEITHER WILLFUL KNOWN TO COLLECT
FULL -- IT REQUIRES A ONE YOUR
ESCROW ACCOUNT AND IT REALLY THE
BILL THAT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
SETS UP A MECHANISM TO ENSURE
FAILURE OF CARE TO ENSURE THAT
THE STORAGE OF ORGANIZATION GOES
WAY AND INSURANCE AT A
GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER OF THE OF
THE CARE PRO.
OF THE STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM.
AND THAT IS WHERE THE FISCAL IS
IN IN THAT THEIR THREE LANES IN
THE BILL THAT ALLOWS.
POWER CYCLE THEN TO RUN THE
PROGRAM IN ANY MANNER THEY SEE
FIT IT'S A IT'S A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR YOUR PROGRAM AND AND CARE
ENDING IN CALORIES I WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO AS A C. AS THEY SEE
FIT ANYTHING THEY WANT TO DO AND
THAT'S THE FISCAL AND WE WOULD.
ASK EITHER THE THE THE LANGUAGE
YOU WOULD FORCE CARE OUT OF
BUSINESS BE STRICKEN FROM THE
BILL AND JUST DO WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL STAGE WHICH
IS.
YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS SHOULD
CARE ON ITS OWN GO AWAY -- WE
EITHER ASK THAT LANGUAGE BE
STRICKEN OR ASTRONAUT NEXT.
THANK YOU. FOR MY CLOTHES FELL
KEY SO WE GOT JOHN NOT.
AS JOHN MONTH ON THE HAPPEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CARPET AND RUG
INSTITUTE WE ARE OPPOSED AS WELL
FOR SIMILAR REASONS YEAH 100%
RESERVE FUND IS MASSIVE AND THE
FINES AND PENALTIES.
ARE NOT COMMENSURATE WITH THE
PROGRAM OF THIS SIZE AND
INDUSTRY THE SIZE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL POSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT THIS HAS NO
STATE COSTS IN IT IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
DOCTOR PARK YES YOU THERE'S NO
STATE COSTS AND IT'S A FISCAL
COMMITTEE I ASK YOU ARRIVE A
THANK YOU.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
I WANNA -- THANK THE MEMBERS
THIS COMMITTEE WHO ARE ALWAYS
WILLING TO BE TEAM PLAYERS AND
PRESENT FOR OTHER MEMBERS WHO
ARE HERE IN TIME.
AT TOMORROW WE WILL DISPENSE OF
THE REMAINING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLS THAT ARE ON
SUSPENSE FILE [inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY IMMEDIATELY AFTER --
SESSION TOMORROW SO HOPEFULLY
PEOPLE CAN GET HERE ON TIME SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM --
WITH THAT THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING IS DONE WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MISTER CALDERON A MYSTERY GARCIA
FOR FIVE MINUTES THANK YOU